you may have noticed your lefty friends
have suddenly gone mum on Donald Trump's
alleged nefarious collusion with Russia
that's because after 11 months of
incessant accusations that Trump is a
Putin puppet it turns out that the
Democrats colluded with Russia you
cannot make this up we will analyze the
most egregious political hypocrisy since
all of the other parts of Hillary
Clinton's campaign then Alicia crass and
Jacob berry joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss Kid Rock's
abdicating his civic duty Frederika
Wilson's 16th minute of Fame and why men
would rather play video games than work
I can't imagine
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knoll Joe
[Music]
this is my favorite news cycle in a very
long time but first we can't get to it
because we've hit the big time
we have finally hit the big time
Marshall we have a new sponsor we have
someone that is going to keep you
employed keep me in Co FFA and the
lights running and this is a good one
this is movement watches MV MT but we
pronounce it movement cuz look we don't
have time for all those vowels we got to
move we have places to be people to see
movement watches it was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank
now I've ordered my movement watch one
of the great things about doing this
show obviously Ben hasn't paid me in in
years but I do get some freebies when we
get to try out the products I have been
waiting I've been salivating for
movement to advertise with us I just
ordered the watch from them and I'm
actually kind of kicking myself because
they have this new line that just came
out today I think or yesterday called
revolver and these watches are some of
the nicest ones they put out yet but I
love watches I have a nice watch
collection but I hate I despise
overpaying for watches you go into a
department store you pay $300 $400 more
than that $500 for you know the watches
are nice but I don't want to spend $500
on movement watches begin at $95 just
$95 for a beautiful watch it's sleek its
modern but it's got a pretty cool
vintage feel on a lot of their models
especially the one that I got I got the
titanium white chrono and it's true
becoming in a few days I'll start
wearing it then it's really cool the
guys who started it they they figured it
out in college they wanted nice watches
they didn't want to pay a lot for it so
what would you do well you'd start your
own watch company right that's what they
did you know they start at $95 they
figured out that by selling them online
you don't need to mark it up like crazy
and pay all of these advertising fees
and everything like that so they've sold
over 1 million watches so far this is by
far the fastest growing watch company in
the world they've sold a million watches
to 160 countries it's you know it's
really nice it's the the name of the
game here is kind of minimalism it's not
one of those really gaudy watches that
like brushes your teeth for you it's
really sleek
you can you can wear it up you can dress
it up you can wear it as your everyday
watch I'm I'm gonna try to twist the arm
of our of the people who do our ads and
try to get a few so I can play around
with them that the other nice thing is
that today you get 15% off if you use
the promo code and Marshall what do you
think that promo code is I'd say it
would be cuff fa so what you have to do
right now you get free shipping you get
free returns you have to go to MVM t.com
slash cough fa that is co v fe fe any
company that is willing to give you a
discount for the word cuff fa go over
there right now give them some love man
that is a great thing
MVM t.com slash cuff fa now is the time
to step up your watch game if you're a
serious person you got it you know you
got places to be people to see so you
got to wear watch MVM t.com slash cough
fa join the movement okay they're
obviously they're a great company and
you got to support them so do you
remember listen I'm a little older than
you
dear dear listener and viewer so do you
remember how Democrats have spent the
last 11 months breathlessly accusing
Donald Trump and Republicans of quote
colluding with Russia you don't remember
I know people those political memories
are very short let me jog your memory
this week we saw cold hard evidence of
the Trump campaign indeed the Trump
family eagerly intending to collude
possibly with Russia
well that's because he'd rather have a
puppet as president and okok today nope
it's pretty clear it's pretty clear you
won't admit the Russians have engaged in
cyber attacks against the United States
of America that you encouraged espionage
against our people that you are willing
to spout the Putin line sign up for his
wish list rake up NATO do whatever he
wants to do and that you continue to get
help from him
because he has a very clear favorite in
this race Clinton told USA Today Susan
page she is quote convinced Trump
associates colluded with Russia to help
her opponent win she's convinced Hillary
says it folks she got it when his
Hillary Clinton never lied let me ask
you that they have been harping on this
for 11 months now and then it just went
away and then just overnight it just
went away and you don't see it reported
anymore
for some reason it dropped out of the
news my fiancee I was writing the show a
few mornings ago my fiancee sweet little
Alisa came at all bleary-eyed you said
Mike what happened to Russia
what what I don't know what happened to
Russia I assumed they stopped talking
about it because it ran out of steam you
know that they kept trying to imply the
Trump who is a guy that we've known for
four decades he's been in the public eye
forever that he was some kind of
Manchurian Candidate even top Democrats
like Van Jones admitted that this was
nonsense cyber war is real war so you
have an active attack on our country and
you have the president-elect cannot find
it in himself to say this is wrong and
it needs to stop amen
things a big nothing boat really you
don't think that the Russia things a big
nothing burger there's nothing you can
do so I thought I assume that was wide
that this ran out of steam they just
realized it wasn't gonna go anywhere
they used it as a cudgel as long as they
could but that's it eventually you can't
you can't beat a dead horse no no that's
not what it seems like now apparently
now the reason they've shut their mouths
about it is because the Democrats may
have colluded with Russia we've learned
that just this you couldn't write this
you couldn't script a better end to this
nonsense that they've been spouting for
11 months now they do this a lot the
Democrats do this a lot they project on
to Republicans the things that are true
of themselves so they harp on forever
and ever to say the fox news is fake
news you know it's fake news and you you
don't get reliable news like us
meanwhile CNN is running fraudulent
stories a story within the last three
months so bad they had to fire an entire
news team for it New York Times their
major story on Trump Russia collusion
they had to retract it they had to
retract the whole story Jim Comey said
that it was fake news under oath when he
was testifying before Congress the other
one that they use a lot is that
Republicans are hateful and extreme so
I'll say you know you guys you just hate
every your haters your bigoted your
racist sexist this that and the other
thing meanwhile it's almost exclusively
Democrats or torching cities torching
campuses censoring speech they have to
spend six hundred thousand dollars to
protect ben shapiro when he comes to
berkeley because he's going to talk
about how you shouldn't sense her speech
but no it's the republicans who are the
hateful ones they say republicans deny
science meanwhile it's the Democrats who
are the ones that who insist that a man
can physically become a woman as long as
he wishes it very much or he imagines it
or he identifies as that in some
metaphysical way right denying science
fake news hateful and bigoted they throw
it on us but obviously it seems to apply
more accurately to them now by collusion
I am NOT just talking about the time
that Barack Obama publicly on video and
on microphone
promised the President of Russia Dmitry
Medvedev that he would lie to the
American people to benefit Russian
interests but to jog your memory here it
is
that's unbelievable this is my last
election I'll have more flexibility
after my election I will transmit this
information to Vladimir so we caught him
on a video doing that but that's not
just what I'm talking about
we NBC News is now reporting special
councilor Muller who is investigating
the Trump Russia connections he is
investigating also Democrat lobbyist
Tony Podesta Podesta why does that name
sound familiar ah yes because he's the
brother of the chairman of Hillary
Clinton's presidential campaign
so apparently Podesta and the Podesta
group may have violated the foreign
agents Registration Act which is a
felony by the way he failed to disclose
lucrative lobbying for Russian interests
in the Ukraine that isn't all we know we
also know that the FBI had evidence for
two years that Russian agents including
a major sleeper cell was trying to
infiltrate the Clinton circle we know
that a Putin lacked Putin linked bank
paid Bill Clinton $500,000 half a
million dollars just a few weeks after
hillary helped American executives
travel to Moscow to support putin's
interests to build his own version of
Silicon Valley to build up his own
Russian tech industry we also know that
the Obama administration knew about
Russian bribery before cutting a deal to
give Russia a major chunk of the u.s.
uranium supply the FBI knew as early as
2009 that the Kremlin had compromised an
American uranium trucking company Russia
received two million dollars in
kickbacks in violation of the foreign
corruptions Practices Act they Russian
nuclear officials transported millions
of dollars into the United States with
the express purpose of benefiting the
Clinton Foundation the Clinton Global
Initiative to try to buy their way into
the Clinton circle in the State
Department we know that that Obama's
Attorney General Eric Holder who is the
most corrupt Attorney General until his
next Attorney General Loretta Lynch we
know that he did not bring charges about
this until the nuclear deals were cut
and we know that the first deal uranium
1b of Russia control over 20% of
America's uranium supply that is a
little bit more than
Nancy Pelosi and Hillary Clinton were
throwing at Donald Trump they said well
there was too many pep Amiens on Twitter
obviously they colluded with Russia
looks like there's a little bit more
undemocratic Ella's proceed with caution
those in glass houses should not throw
uranium at Republicans let's bring on
our panel to discuss this we have the
Daily wires own Alicia Kraus and the man
you might know from wandering around the
sidewalk muttering to himself Jacob Airy
panel thank you for being here Thank You
Alicia the question on everyone's mind
who most colluded with Russia who is the
most nefarious Putin stooge Manchurian
politician is it the Democrats or the
Republicans I don't know that I can
answer that off the top of my head but
can I just shout feminists because Emily
zanotti had a really great piece over at
the Daily wire earlier today in which
she said that feminists actually
accidentally touted Russia's propaganda
when they planned their whole women's
March thing and I liked spent so much
time pointing and laughing at that this
morning it just brought me so much Glee
and and as the mother on the show today
I would just like to say that no one
should ever be throwing uranium do not
throw uranium keep it down kids and you
gave you gave the only answer that I
that is better than Democrats and that's
feminists blame the feminists I do for
everything Jacob why did it take so long
for the media to cover the Russia
corruption on the Left I noticed there's
been breathless coverage on the right
how come it's taken this long we've
known about this for years now we've
known about this for eight years I think
it's partially due to social media and
people are going what about ISM like
they're saying you know when there's oil
Trump's son met with a Russian lawyer or
whatever and they're like what about
Hillary's Dyl to bring in a oil a
Russian oil company to the United States
and now they can't ignore it because
before you just had to take the
journalists words for it right you had
to go to the CNN and go to the New York
Times and even Fox News but now with
social media people are actually calling
out the mainstream media for all these
mistakes so now they can't hide it
anymore now when they're actually
perpetuating these these fake news
stories people are noticing and they're
and they're and they're holding them
accountable do you think it's sinking in
with Demi
gratz I mean obviously Van Jones is
admitting it's a nothing burger but with
the rank-and-file democrats do you think
it's sinking in that this Trump Russia
collusion thing is ridiculous that it's
not going to get them anywhere
politically I think they thought it was
ridiculous to begin with again it's one
of those look don't look at yourself in
the mirror type type of situations you
know don't you know the pot calling the
kettle black in this case I think that
they knew it from the beginning and but
now the American people are going listen
we want to talk about jobs Trump one
let's talk about the economy let's talk
about our foreign policy which was
disastrous for the last eight years so I
think they've just decided we just need
to move on because the American people
aren't taking our bull crap anymore you
watch your language mister this is my
mom would call that imitation cussing
Jake we do even even our even our
expletives are wholesome once that's
what we tried to do on a family show
okay well we need to get to one of the
craziest Democrats in the entire planet
Frederika Wilson and her 16th minute of
fame we have to talk about why men would
rather play video games than do their
jobs shocking we have a lot of other
things to cover but unfortunately you
can't see it if you are not subscribed
to the daily wire you can't see the rest
of the show we have a lot more coming up
if you subscribe right now you'll pay
$10 a month or $100 for an annual
membership you'll get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show I know
we've heard in a million times what
about this fellas what about this in
light of the new the new information
that's come to the surface that
Democrats have colluded with Russia this
leftist here's tumblr you're gonna need
about a hundred of these you're gonna
have to put them all over your house
it's going to be a no alike torrent of
salty salty floods and you can serve
those tears hot or cold they'll always
be salty and delicious we can get the
Frederika wilson vintage we can get the
hilary vintage it's gonna become you're
not gonna know what to do with them
you'll get creative and make your own
blends so go over there right now daily
wire.com get all the shows get the ad
free website and get your leftist here's
tumblr we'll be
speaking of crazy democrat conspiracy
theories let's get into Frederico Wilson
a woman who actually does wear a tinfoil
cowboy hat she is and of course it's a
Florida woman right Florida woman is
seeking her 16th minute of fame
politicizing a heroic fallen soldier she
is now calling the incident in which the
soldier in question was killed
Trump's Benghazi here she is this is
going to be this administration's
Benghazi this is going to be Trump's
Benghazi Trump's lajiye I really like
this attack that they're trying now
I think the attack is gonna fall flat
but what she probably doesn't realize is
that by calling this Niger attack
Trump's Benghazi she's acknowledging
that Benghazi has Benghazi right she's
acknowledging that Benghazi is a
Hillary's Benghazi which they denied for
years and now it's convenient so they'll
have to admit reality Washington Post is
already jumping on this bandwagon
they're saying there was a fight for an
hour or two hours and Donald Trump
didn't do anything I mean the Washington
Post has lost any credibility if it ever
possessed any but it is really pathetic
it's so transparent and thankfully their
friends at Google News through this
story to the top of the heap today
global stories worldwide they threw this
one right up there Jacob has this sunk
in with Democrats yet or are they ready
to admit obviously there's a premise
there's an implication that if this is
Trump's Benghazi than Benghazi was
Hillary's Benghazi would they be willing
to admit that now now that Hillary is no
longer a candidate she's not gonna run
again until 2020 and 2024 and 20:28 and
2032 so will they admit that that was a
huge failure both in the event and the
cover-up honestly think no I think
Congress congresswoman I think she
slipped I think it was a Freudian slip
she messed up I'm sure she probably
meant probably meant to say Iraq or
Afghanistan
and but just Benghazi popped into her
head I really honestly think that it was
either that or she's a Bernie sister and
she wants someone like Elizabeth Warren
or Bernie Sanders to challenge Trump in
2020 but I honestly I I doubt that I
honestly think she's just so kooky
she forgot oh my gosh Benghazi happened
during the the Obama administration she
just she just didn't put two and two
together it was disgraceful they asked
her about the controversy and how she's
politicized gold star families and her
response was I'm a rock star now yeah
that was a rich quote that was
ridiculous and to be honest she's not a
supporter of veterans she's blocked or
attempted to block reforms of the
veteran Veteran Affairs Department she's
voted against funding to go to other
veteran veteran legislation I'm telling
you she is just playing this up and like
she said she's a rock star she's a rock
storm Alicia is Niger Trump's Benghazi
is there any small ounce of truth to
that accusation I'm a big fan of general
Dempsey and general Dempsey had a pretty
in-depth press conference yesterday in
which for some Fox News reporters and of
course all members of the press were
there and asked him very direct
questions about why were we there
why did sergeant Johnson go missing how
did the the DoD handle it what was the
White House's response when the White
House find out and he had answers for
all of these questions questions that if
you'd asked the Obama administration the
same thing after Benghazi they did not
have the answers to and they sent
secretary rice out there on her Sunday
show right around up you know lying and
spreading lies about it another thing
that they lied about that we've talked
about in the news today is sergeant Bowe
Bergdahl you know we had rice tell us
that he served with honor and
distinction and now he could go to
prison for life because he admitted to
desertion desertion that put his fellow
troops at risk so I got six of them
killed six six soldiers were killed
looking for the guy yeah and so there
there's definitely I agree with Jacob I
think congresswoman Wilson maybe had a
Freudian slip and didn't mean to say
that because not only would this reopen
the Benghazi discussion in the
mainstream media if they were actually
doing their jobs regarding Hillary
Clinton's involvement but President
Barack Obama
involvement as well yes and just for
those of you who are unaware a Freudian
slip is where you say one thing but you
mean your mother
general Dempsey did not blame the attack
on a YouTube video I noticed as you
pointed out is there forget Trump for a
minute and Hillary is there any way to
compare what happened in Benghazi to our
consulate first American ambassador
killed in decades and this operation
that happened in Niger is there any
moral equivalence at all okay are you
asking me or I'm always asking you
lunatic ravings I'll talk to Jane no I
think no there is ZERO comparison
especially because you saw that
ambassador Stevens had sent hundreds of
requests for security as you mentioned
he was a diplomat there it was a
compound there that should have been
protected that the depart the State
Department totally failed on this was a
DoD mission this was a military mission
they were there and it seems as if there
is an awful mishap in which sergeant
Johnson came upon the enemy in an area
that they didn't expect to happen and
that's why he went missing and they
didn't find his body until two days
later and I am a big fan of veterans I
come from a military family one of my
dearest friends it's a Goldstar Widow
Jane Horton and I think that Trump's
response to this has not been
appropriate but congresswoman Wilson
should be ashamed of herself I
understand that she has a personal
relationship with this family but you do
not use this as a political you know go
ahead and that's exactly what she's done
and it's really unfortunate absolutely
right and you know I do see the one
mistake you made there in your analysis
at Benghazi you clearly missed all of
the humor that ambassador Stevens was
putting into his emails some people
forget that when asked why Hillary
Clinton didn't give him the security
that he asked for she said all that old
Chris Stevens he's such a jokester I was
one of the best things about Chris you
guys don't understand it but when he was
begging for additional security because
they were worried about Ronnie it was
just a joke joke it was yes so I mean we
try to try to read the humor a little
bit next time Alicia it's like you can't
you don't even understand these Clinton
emails okay we've got to move on I can't
if we talk about Hillary Clinton anymore
rip my hair out we need to talk about
someone else who has abdicated public
service Kid Rock I'm sorry to say Kid
Rock he's not running for Senate we're
all looking forward to it this was the
maggot revolution this is the next phase
of it I would actually argue I gotta say
I don't think it was a matter revolution
I know you love you some Donald Trump
Michaels I like Kid Rock has done more
for the Republican Party and
presidential nominee Opie presidential
nominees than donald trump ever did
until he ran in 20-something ferment
freakin romney i mean it's hilarious and
then I let my favorite kid rock quote of
all time is when he was asked what he
thought thought about Mitt Romney he
said that's a like he said that's like a
decent F word dude I am really
disappointed because I wanted the
battles of the late 90s early 2000s like
music artists to happen in 2020 or
whether it was in the Senate race like
Eminem versus Kid Rock I was really
waiting for it to happen and recently
while listening to Kid Rock when he
shouted my name is kid my four-year-old
said why is his name kid and I was like
no cuz he isn't a kid but he might be
senator of Michigan one day senator kid
I know it is really sad and by the way
when I think of rock and roll I do think
of Mitt Romney you could you could have
had Snoop dignity doo-wop having some
new songs and the election cycle all of
that is gone I did call this right when
it came out everyone is there was a
little website that went up Kid Rock for
Senate everyone was freaking out the way
you knew it wasn't real is that it was
paid for by a company it was just paid
for by a regular old I forget what it
was a record label or his personal
company hey it wouldn't have worked with
the FEC so I unfortunately had a gut
feeling all the way going in that Kid
Rock was not going to serve our country
as we all hoped you would Jacob is this
a positive sign for the culture or is it
devastatingly sad both I think that it
is both sad and that it is a positive
sign for a vulture how bright a brave
position you're staking out here yeah I
got it you got to have it both ways but
I I don't think it was I don't think it
was realistic to begin with I think that
he just did it he sold a lot of t-shirts
a lot of merch so he's happy I think he
probably could have gotten away with it
if he had ran in Florida or Minnesota
but Michigan they tend to take their
politics just a little bit more
seriously some people think that's what
Donald Trump was doing but he was just
out there selling hats and then by the
end of the joke he became the president
really done it I mean Brock has a
statement out that like base just breaks
down in layman's terms the importance of
smaller government and why big
government sucks and I'm like oh my god
I love this I mean I would have
relocated to Michigan where my in-laws
are vote for him seriously well at least
we don't need to move the Daily wire
studios now that's one good thing okay
in nothing sums up 2017 more than this
next story there's a new study out that
shows that men are grown men are playing
more video games now they're
underemployed as a result of it and that
they would they're actually happier so
they'd rather play video games than go
to work and it's made them happier which
is somewhat surprising according to
research from economists from Princeton
the University of Rochester and UChicago
a non college educated men are spending
as much as 40 hours a week playing video
games and evidence shows that the reason
they're doing this is because young men
like instant gratification you don't say
[Laughter]
one of the professor's happiness has
gone up for this group despite
employment percentages having fallen
this is like a fox Butterfield by the
way they would say crime drops despite
prisons filling where they think it's a
paradox but really it makes perfect
sense
yes happiness has gone up as these men
aren't working anymore living with their
parents is going up and that's different
than for any other group
Alicia is there a cultural analog here
to anything or is this something new is
this something we should be worried
about all these young rapscallions
playing their video games and listening
to rock and roll well it's been a
problem that we've had with Millennials
in general not just millennial men this
study showed that 88% of those men are
still going out and getting jobs but now
the number is up to 22% that just really
don't
about getting jobs something that I
could tell them would potentially give
them instant gratification is if you get
a job you get a woman and then that's
something else that gratifies you so
maybe you guys should go out and do that
because it doesn't just help you as an
individual studies also show preview
videos have shown that that men who are
married and have a family tend to end up
making more money men like to make money
they like to feel like they are
protecting and providing sorry guys this
is a basic instincts that God gave you
so when you do those things it's going
to make you happier in the long run
especially if you that can invest in
your future in the offspring and in the
it's also going to positively affect the
economy I think millenials all around
have really screwed the American economy
because they're delaying getting married
having a family which leads to creating
jobs when you buy a house build a
business etc etc that is true making
money is a lot more fun than not making
money I've spent long swaths of time not
making any money degree and well that's
because marshals never gotten the
privilege of experiencing the other one
but I did because I published blank
pages and it's the best man it is it's
really a shame that you know that says
more about the culture well one cultural
analog here I do think is Alicia you
mentioned that sometimes it's nice for
young men to have young women to
accompany them doing different variants
your marriage Michael is right it's a
whole absolutely only after marriage and
you got to be praying the whole time but
but there is this trend that we've been
observing especially in Japan that's
where a lot of studies have come out but
all over which is that men are choosing
porn over real-life women there you know
once the sex robots come the whole
species is going to die out Jacob is
this is this the direction the cultures
headed they were moving toward digital
instant gratification rather than
engaging with real people and actually
producing something you know we're
shooting people on Halo but we're not
building businesses we're linking over
at sex robots but we're not making our
wife happy I honestly think that this is
going this direction but I honestly
think it'll be in the short term it'll
burn out because
it'll just it'll just everyone will just
notice oh this is fake it may be instant
most people want a a permanent sort of
fulfillment for their soul so I honestly
believe that yes we'll see this in the
short-term and it's devastating and it's
quite frankly annoying even me as an as
a nerd I like making that money you know
but I would love to see I would love to
see this burn out and I honestly think
it will it's just this'll this is a
trend that'll pass once once these guys
wake up and they realize oh my gosh my
parents have died and I have no money
that's a really sad way to end the show
but you actually do bring up a good
point which is we've seen this in other
industries too right you know for 60
years after World War two the mainstream
news media had this domination of
American culture until 2017 when Donald
Trump just drowned them all in Kofa face
because people realize they don't want
to fake things they want the real thing
they don't want to just be bombarded
with a bunch of fake news even something
as powerful as the mainstream news media
after a while people get sick of what is
fake and they prefer the real thing
excellent point Alicia and Jacob thank
you for being here thank Alicia crabs
from The Daily wire and Jacob berry from
muttering around the sidewalks all right
that's our show
today I should point out is my fiancee
sweet little Elise's birthday so happy
birthday to her you can send all of your
presents - yeah you can say it they're
really the best present that you could
give her is to subscribe to the daily
wire subscribe on Facebook and subscribe
on YouTube and then you keep getting all
of all of that real news coming right to
you just a steady stream of kff a I'm
sure that's really all she wants today
and also speaking of podcasts you should
listen to Andrew Klavan has given me the
last role that I'm ever going to get in
Hollywood it's for his new podcast
andrew clavin's another Kingdom it's a
narrative podcast Hollywood is crumbling
I obviously got my role because Drew was
wearing a bathrobe in a hotel room but
that is over now Hollywood is crumbling
the edifices are falling down and
conservatives now don't have to worry
about gatekeepers and we can make our
own art and we can make our own culture
and you should all support that and it's
also a really fun story so come on over
it's andrew clavin's another
kingdom I perform it I'll never work in
this town again
so please enjoy my last role get your
mailbag questions in for Thursday and
we'll see you tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
you
[Music]